[Music]
hi good evening thank you for coming out
tonight and thank you to the world
science festival for hosting this
program and thank you to our other
participants who are now going to be
joining me on stage and then I will
introduce them starting from at the far
left
Rachel Rosen is a an assistant professor
of theoretical physics at Columbia
University where research focuses on
gravity quantum field theory and the
intersection of the two thank you Rachel
jabo barca is the leader of the Columbia
experimental gravity group in Lego and a
professor of physics at Columbia
University
[Applause]
Maria's parappa Liu is a physics
professor at Caltech she's been
researching elementary particles in
their interactions at Fermilab Tevatron
and CERN's Large Hadron Collider David
gross is the Chancellor's chair
professor of theoretical physics at the
University of California Santa Barbara
he was awarded the 2004 Nobel Prize in
Physics for his discovery of asymptotic
freedom which led to the formulation of
quantum chromodynamics and Pedro
Ferreira is a professor of astrophysics
at the University of Oxford
his most recent book the perfect theory
is published in over in more than 20
countries so I'd like to open tonight
what we're going to do you know there's
been a lot of talk about gravitational
waves this week and a lot of it has been
technical and there's going to be
another talk after this in the Skirball
Center and a lot of it is technical in
heart science and I thought that maybe
tonight here in this panel we could have
a little a little looser interpretation
maybe more philosophical metaphysical
maybe not strictly scientific more
speculative
so I'm going to open up with a question
that I actually asked Kip Thorne a few
weeks ago on the phone Kip was one of
the founders of LIGO and in one of the
recipients of the Cavalier prize earlier
in the week at the festival so I'm going
to ask this question to the panel and
they can answer it and or not answer it
in any way they prefer and and then
after you're done I'll tell you what
Kip's up so my question is what is
gravity stunned silence any order
no just jump in please I wish we really
know so I mean we can certainly it's
easy enough to describe properties of
gravity it's easy enough to describe
theories of gravity we've had two
marvelous theories but what is for
somebody like me raises it the question
marks and not the answers that we
already know so in a deep sense we don't
think we know the answer to that because
of some of the things we'll be probably
discussing later but in a practical
sense if I want to send a moon if I want
to send a rocket to the moon we know
precisely what is gravity or by the way
if I want to calculate the ripples the
waves that might move the arms of LIGO
by a fraction of the size of the proton
I can also calculate that so we have a
pretty good practical understanding of
gravity but conceptually I don't know
right that's one of the ideas I wanted
to introduce to the audience is that
this thing that we take for granted that
we live with we don't even think about
except when it's in headlines is
something that we don't really know what
it is and Kip Thorne's answer was it's a
meaningless question probably the answer
to the the you would get the same answer
to that question like as David's answer
if you ask what is dark matter right so
we know the properties of dark matter
and in
to do with gravity but we don't know
what dark matter is and the other part
of this discussion it's even more so
actually yes you asked what is dark
energy and again it has to do with
gravity but you can't say what it is
right so I don't think it's a
meaningless question but it's a question
to which the answer we don't have today
in a way that we have answers to the
question what is the Higgs boson or what
is the electroweak symmetry or what is
the standard model we don't have the
same kind of answer to what is gravity
and if you if you wish
from an experimental viewpoint we have
we have models and theories of gravity
successively better and better and they
describe nature very well matter of fact
so well that we don't find a way out of
it
we just no more suspect it must be wrong
because it's not a quantum theory that's
why they chose here ok so let's take a
let's begin with a historical
perspective I'll ask Pedro to begin the
discussion as I as I as everybody has
said we don't really know what gravity
is and for most of the history of
civilization gravity as as a concept
wasn't really thought of it wasn't until
Newton came along the people started to
use the word gravitation and to think
about well what what is this thing and
what are its properties and then I'll
ask Pedro to take us briefly from Newton
and especially Einstein as the author of
the book the perfect theory you dealt a
lot with I can give you a whistle-stop
tour through it and I actually can
relate it to something that David said
he said two things he said we can send
rockets to the moon and we can calculate
ripples in space-time
we can send rockets to the moon
basically because you know 300 years ago
a guy called Newton figured out that he
could explain why apples fall to the
surface of the earth or why planets go
around the Sun in terms of a very simple
equation a very simple law and it's this
sum law of universal attraction which is
proportional to the mass of objects and
inversely proportional to the square of
the distance in other words the further
away things are the weaker
says and it works beautifully and it's a
fantastic you can calculate you can
calculate how you send rockets to the
moon very well the interesting thing
about this is it has a bizarre property
in that it's um it's it's has an action
at a distance in other words if it
happens instantaneously there's no
there's no speed in this there's no
information there there's no information
of how how fast this this force
propagates between objects and by the
turn of the beginning of the 20th
century this was a problem because
Einstein had figured out how to marry
the laws of mechanics the laws of how
things move with the laws of light and
I'm not going to go into this but one of
the things that came out of this is that
there was a cosmic speed limit it was
things couldn't propagate faster than a
certain speed so there was this
inconsistency between there's more of
gravity that works remarkably well and
understanding of physics at the
beginning of the 20th century over seven
years he tried to figure out how to
bring things together and he came up
with his his theory of gravity it and at
some point he was completely stuck he
didn't know how to do it he went to his
friend said this is driving me nuts I
just don't know how to do it his friend
gave him a paper and a textbook on
Romanian geometry geometry and Einstein
had to learn this stuff and he figured
out that his theory the way to couch his
theory the way to explain his theory and
so an answer to what is gravity is the
following if you put stuff in space-time
it'll deform space-time if you now throw
stuff through space-time the stuff that
you throw through space-time will feel
the deformations of space-time and will
curve and Bend as if it was feeling a
force coming from the thing that you put
in there initially so that's a kind of a
simple summary of Einstein's theory of
gravity of general relativity so that
was you know that's a that's a three
minute summary of the history of general
relativity and gravity but but within 10
years after Einstein's creation of
general relativity I ran into a problem
with quantum mechanics nice he's gonna
ask David to address that before I do
let me say another point about gravity
which is so you know I often give talks
about
big questions in physics and what we
understand about fundamental laws of
nature and and and I explained to people
like you that gravity is central because
in a sense most of the time it's the
only force any of you ever feel now
actually it's the in ordinary energy
scales or even within the atom it's by
far the weakest possible imaginary
imaginable force and totally negligible
and we particle physicists would do
experiments at LHC for example like
Maria or theorists who work on the
structure of matter atoms molecules
ignored gravity completely for years and
years because it's a weak 40 orders of
magnitude that's a million million
million million million million million
times weaker than the force of
electricity inside the atom but it's the
only force you ever feel and people find
that sort of jarring now why why do you
feel it if it's the weakest possible
force of nature and the reason is
because for two reasons one is that
there's no anti-gravity there's no way
of shielding it two is its universal one
Newton called his theory the universal
theory of gravity because it acts on
everything that possesses mass or energy
and so everything feels it and the
reason you feel gravity is that when you
get up in the morning the whole earth is
pulling you down every atom of the earth
is acting on you and it's there's no
nothing just stopping it there's no
anti-gravity that's not true of all the
other forces electricity there's
positive charge there's negative charge
they attract but they also create when
they come together on neutral object
that has no charged atoms unless you
ionize them are neutral that's why you
don't feel the
a stronger force of electricity and
magnetism and then there's the force
inside the proton in the nucleus that
holds the quartz together which is much
much stronger than electricity and yet
you've never felt it
that's because protons are neutral they
too have a charge we call color charge
which is neutralized by these quarks
coming together and forming a neutral
object so the only forces that remain
are sort of weak molecular forces
between neutral atoms and weak not that
weak nuclear forces between protons and
neutrons but by and large it's shielded
gravity is universal and as was just
explained gravity is universal because
it is in effect has to do with the
dynamics of space and time and space and
time are our most Universal basic
concepts of physical reality we all
construct this picture of space and time
and Einstein tells us that space and
time is dynamical energy and mass curve
it and that's what gives rise to what we
used to call the gravitational force so
it has a certain special role in science
which differentiates it from the other
much much stronger forces universality
no anti-gravity nothing can shield it
but when you extrapolate what we
understand about gravity from Newton and
or Einstein to very high energies and
very small distances quantum mechanics
can comes in to play just as it did with
a much much stronger forces inside the
atom in the nucleus because it's a weak
we can't imagine observing directly
those quantum effects theorists however
can imagine doing experiments at very
high energies and then we run into all
sorts of problems and they have to do
really with the fact that gravity is a
theory of dynamical space-time and in
quantum mechanics everything is
fluctuating
try to observe anything you set it in
motion and therefore we suspect that in
gravity as well if you do observations
at very short distances where the
gravitational force becomes strong you
would see fluctuating space and time
space just wouldn't be something that
exists there it's dynamical and quantum
mechanically fluctuating like mad in
ways which we can't get control so
that's a conceptual problem we face and
there are many other conceptual problems
we'll meet when we might get to which
motivates theorists by and large to try
to marry quantum mechanics and gravity
we are moving along that path with some
recent successes but the answer is far
from clear and the particular which we
might get to later are mind-boggling yes
I want to get to the speculations later
but when you say that space is
fluctuating what do you what do you mean
by that every space in Einstein's
theories of dynamical entity you know
the naive picture that infants create of
space that's when you learned about
space by the way that's how you learned
how to get from crawl across the room
you did it somehow I don't know it's a
major achievement learn about gravity
well you learned about something that
was holding you to the floor but but
more I think much more important you
constructed a model of of events taking
place in space and in time not trivial
tasks is nobody knows how to teach a
computer to construct a model of space
and time but then we learned that you
know it's really space-time and then we
learned both from Einstein that it's not
just there is not just a coordinate
system it's just it's not just a rigid
and it's not it's dynamical it it can be
curved if I if I put a Sun into this row
that the Sun into this room we would
slightly curved
space it would no longer be Euclidean
flat it would be curved like the surface
of the earth is curved and and that you
can't explain the motion of particles in
the vicinity of the Sun by saying
they're moving in straight lines
accepted in this curved space so it
looks like they deviate and can we
anything dynamical in quantum mechanics
is fluctuating
you know that's Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle you can't be at rest at a
given place because if you try to
observe that you have to interact with
that system and you set it in motion
well space itself is dynamical and when
you try to observe the structure of
space what is space really you set it in
motion and that's such a incredibly
small effect in this room that we don't
worry about it we can simply say space
is fixed we know but if you try to
observe space the structure of space at
very short distances according to
Einstein's theory and the rules of
quantum mechanics the fluctuations of
space itself would be so immense and
uncontrollable that we suspect that
something goes wrong with our model of
space and time which largely dates back
to the first few months of our life yeah
I just wanted to say that this alludes
to the fact that in the origins of
space-time are being considered now to
be quantum mechanical so quantum
mechanics is the place where space-time
emerges it's not just classical under
Stein's theory of relativity is a
classical theory but the underpinning of
space-time as a dynamical system which
is not just a stage where we move on a
stage but it actually emerges is good
is quantum mechanical and that's where
the fluctuation then is tiny
fluctuations can be thought of like the
fluctuations where at the beginning and
then they smooth out from our
perspective they look smooth because you
observe
yep just like you know you look smooth
but I know you're mostly vacuum so but
also we can say one thing that the kind
of the question that emerges from this
is that if you are considering the mass
in general theory of relativity as the
source of the curvature of space-time
and therefore gravity exists and then we
learned that elementary particles get
their mass through a quantum theory
quantum field theory for not phenomenon
the phenomenon of the Higgs mechanism so
the question that people ask a lot of
times how does the Higgs who and ausmus
to the particles connected to gravity
and these are questions that we don't
have answers to but but obviously we
talk we start seeing that somehow all of
this is connected and the the conundrum
of gravity has to come to some sort of
an understanding I think sooner than
later
yeah probably sooner now for although
we're talking about general relativity
and we're all treating it in this kind
of common way there was a period which
I'll ask Pedro to expand out a little
bit when general relativity fell in to
know if it was disfavor or just
invisibility or how you would want to
characterize it well so so Einstein
comes up with this theory and for the
next 15 years it's it's a lot of people
are doing calculations and coming up
with wonderful things they solve for
what happens if you put an object in
space time they figure out what happens
to the whole universe
it's what a graduate student of mine
said it's you they were picking the
low-hanging fruit when you come up with
a theory and the initial you know the
initial few years there's all this
beautiful stuff you can calculate quite
easily and then it's younger sister
quantum mechanics came on the scene and
stole the she stole the Thunder quantum
mechanics is great because the general
relativity applies to the very large
quantum mechanics applies to the very
small it applies to stuff you can do in
the lab it's practical people can do
calculations people can go and do
measurements it's so much more
interesting for
assists and not only that it's useful
you know people built the atom bomb and
this meant that a lot of the a lot of
the intellectual activity went into
quantum mechanics was sucked away from
general relativity one of the problems
with general relativity was there were a
few early measurements that tested it
and then there was nothing else you know
there was really nothing that could be
measured there was there was um there
was a meeting in 1957 organized by by a
guy who worked on quantum gravity Bryce
to it and where he brought the
relativists together to say what are we
going to do you know what what are we
what's the future of general relativity
and Simon went to this meeting and I've
got a quote you get went to this meeting
and he was very interested he done he
done quantum electrodynamics he was
looking for one of the next things to do
and he summarized he said there exists
one serious difficulty and that is the
lack of experiments furthermore we're
not going to get any experiments so we
have to take the viewpoint of how to
deal with the problems when no
experiments are available he said well
the best viewpoint is to pretend that
there are experiments in calculate in
this field we are not pushed by
experiments were pulled by imagination
and this really characterized general
relativity first for 30 years until the
early 1960s it still does I mean it
doesn't change like what you know like
Oh uses general relativity uses
gravitational wave will use
gravitational waves to learn about - to
learn about compact objects in the
universe and even black holes but the
kinds of things that Bryce DeWitt was
talking about was trying to understand
quantum gravity and we're in the same
situation and it's because as I said you
know cavitation gravity is such a weak
force its effects at so the highest
energy microscope we have that probe
short distances is the one that Maria
works at at the LHC and it can probe
down to nano nano meters a billionth of
a billionth
of a meter or even farther by now and
100 times farther and they at the LHC
never talk about gravity there are some
wild speculations that they might see
extra dimensions and maybe gravity
effects but those are pretty wild they
don't they don't have to worry about it
or the other way around they're not
lucky enough to be able to explore it
it's still experimentally the problems
that the way it was talking about how to
formulate a consistent quantum
mechanical theory of gravity are
unimaginably beyond experimental direct
study still and it's still the case that
the biggest advances we make in the
field of see Orion understand how to
reconcile quantum mechanics and general
relativity are done by performing
thought experiment experiments much as
Einstein did in formulating the theory
get duncan experiment sharp you were
gonna say yes so so in my view it was
quite natural that that the observation
like behind in gr general relativity
because humanity was not ready we will
not ready technologically and for even
gravitational waves we had to wait
hundred years from the idea of of
gravitational wave until we could
observe it's not because we were stupid
we had to wait because we didn't have
the right technology we had to invent it
and 2016 and we were ready with the
technology I mean it's not a new idea
in the 1950s people already had an idea
of say a laser interferometer it was not
called laser interferometer because
laser was not invented yet
but they actually formulated the fact
that you can use right to tell
gravitational waves but you know 1950s
and 2016 it's a long time yeah you know
a couple of lifespans because we didn't
have the technology and and I think I
think as an experimentalist I have to
express that there will be tests of
general relativity quantum gravity but
maybe we have to get ready
maybe maybe techno
we are not be ready in my lifetime maybe
maybe it's a better job of the young
people sitting in this audience yeah so
I would like to encourage you to learn
about gravity so what changed in the 60s
or after the the 1958 meeting what was
it just technology or was a theory
working with technology what in Chapel
Hill this famous meeting that it was
talking about call so what happened was
there was a transfer of theoretical
technology from quantum field theory
which had the first quantum
electrodynamics and into this classical
field so from a field that was dominated
by people following Einstein and doing
classical calculation you had people who
were knew about relativistic quantum
field theory which was a very difficult
subject in its own but enormous lee
advanced in the end of the 20th century
that's the basis of our standard theory
of particle physics even more and this
is really I think the crux of the matter
is that we did so you know I was a
particle heroes I took a great course on
general relativity from Steven Weinberg
when I was a graduate student I was
wonderful but that was just for cultural
reasons it had no influence on the work
I was trying to do to understand the
strong force however in the course of
constructing this incredibly successful
standard model of particle physics we
discovered that or that the underlying
conceptual structure of the standard
model of particles is in a deep sense
very similar to general relativity there
is a unity of nature that was discovered
and it didn't take long therefore for
people doing particle physics already in
the middle seventies to extrapolate
their theories to the regime where
gravity becomes equally important and to
discover that they all seem to merge at
the same place and furthermore
that new theories like string theory
come unified them and to some extent
that effort to unify the other forces
together with gravity does begin to
resolve some of the paradoxes that that
we had but so nature taught us something
coming from understanding
electromagnetism and the nuclear forces
about gravity and it suggests what has
been for the last thirty years the the
most successful attempt to try to
reconcile the two but but I mean but
that is one strand of the development of
general relativity I mean I think the
thing that happened post night in the
early 60s is there was this field that
was created because of all these people
who work during the war on radar which
is Radio Astronomy they brought these
techniques they looked up at the sky and
they discovered that the universe was
teeming with these objects which were
very powerful radio sources incredibly
powerful and if you worked out how much
energy they had and you know early
sixties people measured how far away
they are they realized that these
objects were immense and these objects
to understand these objects you had to
go back to general relativity these were
very massive objects when space time
would be very curved and you had to go
back to general relativity so that was
one of one of the things that kicked off
and so I think general relativity really
came back it's in Kip Thorne has called
it the Golden Age of general relativity
because of what's been called
relativistic astrophysics is this this
merger of astronomers and and and
relativists in trying to understand
these objects and the advent of black
hole physics is the love that lore the
people I mean it's exciting it's really
remarkable I mean if you you read the
history you know black holes become a
reality in the 1960s yet in the early
nineteen seventies you know they're
established but if you would talk to
astronomers they were still you know it
was you're pushing it black holes
weren't really that real nowadays if you
talk to my colleagues and my I mean I'm
a theorist in an astrophysics department
you talk to them there's no doubt that
there are black holes there are black
holes everywhere there is a black hole
at the center of every galaxy and it
drives a lot of the big research
programs in astrophysics for example in
the next couple of years and a telescope
called the event horizon telescope is
going to try and look at the black hole
at the center of our galaxy so so I
would say that it's it's true what David
is saying about the evolution of quantum
gravity but the way that general
relativity then contaminated astronomy
oh it's a separate thing yeah quantum
effects are again totally negligible but
there's not one other thing you didn't
stress which is was equally important in
that whole era starting with Einstein
immediately which was physical cosmology
in 1915 a hundred years ago when the
theory was formed people still thought
you know the Milky Way was the universe
and and there weren't even other
galaxies and actually knew nothing about
the universe except there were all these
points of light up there they knew they
didn't know about the composition of
stars what makes them shine anything and
a hundred years later we have a this
unbelievable history of the universe in
great detail all of that especially the
large scale cosmology part required
general relativity which Einstein was
the first to construct the model of and
he only did so or initially you know
it's very interesting I marvelous quote
recently from Einstein in which he
writes to his friend ehrenfest
describing his first attempt to
construct a cosmological model of the
universe and that was B and and I I
understood finally what was motivating
in he wrote down these equations
describes gravity he calculated the
Pyrenean of mercury he predicted the
deflection of light and then he said
okay I have these equations they
describe the dynamics of space and time
what is the universe its space-time I
should be able to construct a model of
the universe
but he clearly was scared that it
wouldn't work because what an
extrapolation it's even bigger than
Newton to go from describing gravity
motion of planets to having a theory of
the universe so he constructed a pretty
silly model which was unstable and
introduced the cosmological constant and
so on and he wrote there and fist I feel
so relieved and I understand why I felt
relieved I think because he was worried
that if he took this theory constructed
to explain the motion of planets and so
on
consistent with the relativity principle
and then applied it to the universe
it would be totally inconsistent you
take a theory you construct for a
limited set of phenomena then you
extrapolate it because you must
extrapolate and it had her fails but it
didn't totally fail for at least a few
months I mean it was sensible and he
felt so relieved that his equations were
logically consistent when extrapolated
to the ultimate domain well partly what
defeated him I guess and in terms of
predicting the expansion of the universe
is that he was only that his universe
was one galaxy big and that galaxy is
now it was also put you know Einstein
was a genius buddy like all of us suffer
from prejudices or like hidden
assumptions and if you go out at night
and look at the sky it's beautiful you
go out the next night hasn't changed so
obviously you assume that it never
changes it's eternal there's motion
because we're going around the Sun and
so on but it's it's static so his goal
was to construct a universe that never
changed a static universe with no
beginning no end just permanent and and
boy that was a big mistake because he
otherwise could have predicted the
Hubble expansion of the universe which
would have in my mind have been the
greatest prediction
ever made but he didn't make it well to
rewind from the expansion of the
universe you go back and you go back to
the initial point whatever you want to
call it and that was the the Cosmic
Microwave Background the afterglow of
that event was discovered in the 60s and
that also helped revive the ideas of
general relativity because you wouldn't
need that to be in to explain the
conditions that are at that dance and
the expansion of the universe so that
that opens up what was the phrase you
used which one good one the Golden Age
yeah the gold thank you the Golden Age
that so that was part of the Golden Age
yeah it can I just say something it's
interesting I didn't mention cosmology
what I do is to cosmology so it's
interesting that I ignored so yeah yes
so one one note which is which is less
less about the theoretical development
but more about the science sociological
development yeah I mean gravity up until
quite recently was kind of a boutique
boutique science yeah that if a few
people are very interested I mean even
know that that gravitational waves are
on the front page of every newspaper
just think about that you know less than
10 millionth of humanity actually puts
serious time into this this this science
so in science you need a critical mass
of minds thinking about the same thing
to have a conversation to have advancing
science and actually that really
happened after the 1960s that people
really started to congregate that okay
no this is the next big thing we should
think about it yeah so so I think that
is there is more than you know what we
see scientific development we need we
need human brains actually addressing
and getting interested in this topic and
experiments I mean now we have for
cosmology we have so many missions so
many experiments that it's it's
spectacular it goes to accuracy of the
level that is of the
same as particle physics for example
which is astonishing if you told
somebody 30 years ago they would laugh
at you when you say I'm doing precision
cosmology yeah completely laugh at you
they love dummy and is from particle
physics too like they said you have
perfectly good sight are you crazy
so in terms of cosmology there there
were a couple of developments in the
last the last generation last 20-30
years that I'd like to discuss and they
ultimately bring us back around to the
quantum general relativity disparity but
but before we get to that let's let's
walk through those anomalies Dark Matter
Maria you've been working on that can
you introduce us - right sir Dark Matter
was why it was invoked yes so dark
matter in fact it's been more than 70
years when shrieky Caltech he introduced
dark matter in the clusters of the
galaxies to explain explain the total
energy conservation essentially and in
the sky based on what you see from the
light of the stars and the galaxies and
what you can calculate so he invoked
something which is called the Dunkel
material with the dark matter it was a
phenomenon that had to do with gravity
and there was no characterization of it
and in the past 40 years we have seen
that when we look at rotation curves in
galaxies of stars they they seem to be
instead of following the Newtonian law
and going down they used to yes that
also but let me go first I will explain
that the bullet cluster as well but we
have the the instead of following
Newton's law as will you get out from
the galaxy it looks like they plateau as
if there was extra gravity as if there
was extra gravity which if it wasn't
there it wouldn't hold the stars
together so galaxies will the stars in
the galaxies would fly apart so that's
kind of
because it looks like excess gravity we
can measure it but we don't know what is
the source of this extra gravity what is
it exactly when with the with the
progress in all the Astrophysical
astronomical observations we are able to
look at the sky in radio in X in all
these different wavelengths of the
electromagnetic spectrum so we can see
we can see the universe at the
electromagnetic spectrum and we can see
the universe in terms of gravity as we
said with the velocity curves when we
look at the the picture that we have
here we look at the collision the bullet
cluster and a collision which takes five
hundred thousand years where the the
cluster collision leaves dark matter
seems not to be touched at all and all
the and it's the the blue stuff and all
the red stuff is the is the gas where
the particles are actually colliding so
what is the stuff that galaxies come
together they collide but this stuff
doesn't touch at all and completely
different than the matter that we know
completely different than the
interactions of matter than we know
normal extra magnetic at all we call
this dark matter and we have developed
different kind of scenarios for what it
could be could it be dark stars could it
be the black holes could it be what
could it be we made a lot of
observations the astronomers and
cosmologists made a lot of observations
and they have exploded all sorts of
large objects in the sky that could
compose dark matter and then there was
this revelation that perhaps we can
explain dark matter as a new type of
particle a new type of if you will
something that it is not something
something that it is not included in the
standard model but it's an exotic
particle and what were the properties of
this particle this prior particle should
be weakly interacting so it's likely a
neutrino it
it doesn't it doesn't interact with us
it interacts with us very with normal
mothers super weakly in fact in fact
super super super weakly much weaker
than the Higgs or anything else of the
electroweak theory it's massive so that
it account for the evolution of the
universe with all the cosmological
parameters what is the abundance from
the beginning of the universe and and we
can produce it or colliders or we can
observe it in the sky when it
annihilates with each other or in fact
we can wait for it in detectors there
are massive detectors and wait for a
Dark Matter particle to go and interact
with the width in a nuclear interaction
with the nucleus of an atom if we have a
massive detector let's say with water or
with we can design many detectors or in
or in the detector with silicon and we
can figure out from the recoil if
actually this is a Dark Matter particle
or something else so in particle physics
we developed this idea that it could be
a particle and we had a very good feel
for that it's called supersymmetry that
was giving us such a candidate and I'm
speaking about was and and and and in
the past tense because this there have
been about twenty years where we were we
have been convinced that dark matter is
a particle and we are going to find it
but you all read in the newspapers that
supersymmetry we haven't found any
supersymmetry any hints for
supersymmetry so now we are looking at
the different detectors the different
detectors that we produce we think we
can produce dark matter we look at it in
the form of them in a more exotic form
not just in the form of supersymmetry
and so do all the direct dark matter
experiments that are awaiting there for
a nuclear interaction to happen with
with the Dark Matter particle and the
the range of the masses that we are
exploring are from the very low masses
the G V level at the mass of the proton
let's say but it would be weakly
interacting all the way
500 GeV - the Large Hadron Collider so
if the particle if the Dark Matter
particle whether it is super symmetric
or something else is there we have a
very good chance to triangulate it among
these three ways of experiments the the
experiment the indirect the experiments
in the sky where Dark Matter
annihilation which other and produces
different particles excesses of
particles that we can see or in the
collider experiments when we actually
produce dark matter or in the direct
dark matter underground experiments a
huge project huge program of underground
experiments where we see the nuclear
interactions with the active volume of a
detector so the status the there is a
proliferation of Dark Matter experiments
and we have been saying in the past you
know 10 years we have been saying that
we are right around the corner to
discover Dark Matter and I think we are
if with the dark if dark matter is a
particle we really are right around the
corner because we have cornered it from
so many experimental sources that it has
got to be it has got to be reachable in
the very close foreseeable future with
all the experimental program that we
have said it about well I'm not
contradicting you but I for my research
that beginning around 1980 people would
say we'll have the Dark Matter particle
in five years and then in 1985 was five
years go on and so forth yes that is
correct
things like cutting the but you know the
deficit it has the same however I will I
will remind you it has been the same for
the Higgs it was right around the corner
for five years every year for a very
long time and you know it took a little
bit of a corner to go from the Tevatron
to the LHC and then we turned that
corner but that [ __ ] I think if it's a
particle it has to reveal itself in the
in this and the next generation of
experiments we cannot we are not going
to be going to be shooting in the dark
if if if we go beyond the next
generation of experiments in Dark
Matters I mean it's not a search for
something you don't know anything about
correct we know precisely we don't know
what it is but whatever matter it is
we know how much there is in the
universe and you can see it there by the
way you know that blue you might wonder
why why is that colored blue that's
because you don't actually see it see
directly that's that what you see are
those bright sources those white things
those are quasars behind the cluster
shining light through it and then as
Einstein once explained in a beautiful
paper he said you know massive matter is
like a lens light passes around matter
gets deflected so what you see there and
the way the observers measure the dark
matter even though they can't see it
with look directly with light they can
measure the bending of light in the
gravitational field produced by that
matter
so that's why you you can see it you can
measure it you can count how much there
is and it's we say 90% of the matter in
the universe is is in the form of this
dark matter quite precisely which is
amazing most of the matter is not made
of the stuff that we're made out of and
we don't know what it is it could be
particles probably as particles but
since we know how much there is and and
we we have strong constraints on what
mass it could have this is the plot the
pie chart there so the 25% of the energy
the whole energy density of the universe
is a dark matter if you take matter
that's 90% of the matter and the
ordinary matter the little five percent
of our magical stuff that we are made of
are the stuff that we can explain with
particle physics to twenty four orders
of magnitude extremely precisely the
phenomena in in energy so so that dark
matter with which all the the inference
of dark matter is due to its
gravitational interactions but we cannot
we cannot really say
is it a particle yes or no we we had the
McCall the WIMP miracle and wimp stands
for weekly interactive weakly
interacting massive particle and people
are today they're talking about the
simple which is the strongly interactive
massing part of massive particle because
we the week within weakly interacting
one and this kind of a miracle that you
would have a hundred GeV of weekly of
wimps that would fit the the that would
fit the model and would give you the
Dark Matter that we calculate in the
universe is just not having any we don't
have any positive results as a particle
so while we think and we have good
calculations and we think we have a good
we're not going and in the darkest as
David said we have a theory and we have
good calculations of how a particle like
that would interact and we can calculate
we can do a lot of calculations and we
have experiments while this is happening
we should keep an open mind and and yes
it's a the the the particle fits the
bill but until you if you don't discover
it then it doesn't you cannot force it
to be so I think we have to keep an open
eye and open mind on that the other part
of cosmology in the last generation or
two that involves gravity but has left
us with the mystery as dark energy and
Rachel you've been researching that so
can you explain to us what why we needed
to invoke dark energy and what kind of
research sure yeah maybe I can give a
little bit of a history which we touched
on before so as recently as the 1920s as
was stated it was widely believed even
by Einstein that the universe was was
static that it hadn't evolved in time
that it looked more or less the same it
didn't have a beginning it didn't have
an end and in fact when Einstein tried
to describe this static universe of
course if gravity is the dominant force
at acts that acts at very large scales
what you would expect is a universe that
will collapse over time because you only
have this attractive force at large
scales so in order to write
a static universe Einstein had to
introduce this extra factor an extra
parameter in these theories it didn't
have a good physical interpretation but
it was allowed by the theory and you
could just stick in this extra factor in
order to sort of stabilize the universe
or at least give you a static solution
although it wasn't wasn't ultimately
stable but it was at the end of the
1920s there was a series of observations
and in particular those of Edwin Hubble
who looked at distance galaxies distant
galaxies and noted that they were moving
away from us and not only were they
moving away from us the ones that were
farther from us were moving away at a at
a faster rate and so if you believe that
that our place in the universe is not a
special place in the universe that we're
not at the center of the universe and
everything's just moving away from us
what this means is that the universe has
to be expanding that everything in the
universe is moving away from everything
else so so this is somewhat
revolutionary idea what it meant for
Einstein's equations though and for
Einstein's theory is he could get rid of
this parameter that he had introduced by
hand because you could imagine a
universe that started out with some
initial kick that everything was
expanding away from everything else
gravity still the dominant force that's
large scales so over time even though
everything's expanding it might slow
down and start to contract again so it
was even more revolutionary than when in
1998 people observing distant supernovae
noticed that not only was the universe
expanding but it was expanding an
accelerating rate so stuff was moving
away from us faster and faster and again
gravity should be the dominant force at
large scales there was nothing there to
explain what would be pushing everything
away from everything else at a faster
and faster rate so there are possible
interpretations of what this could be
and I think the most common one is
what's known as vacuum energy so this is
an idea that that comes from quantum
field theory which is a theory of
particle physics which tells us that
that empty space is not in fact empty so
this is going back to what we were
discussing earlier as soon as you invoke
quantum mechanics everything becomes
dynamical everything is fluctuating so
even if you have a vacuum with nope
articles in it what quantum field theory
is telling you is that you can produce
pairs of particles that then disappear
again but there's an energy associated
with this process so there's an energy
of empty space and in fact it turns out
that this energy would have this effect
of causing the expansion of the universe
to accelerate this vacuum energy all
right so that's fantastic so you can go
ahead in quantum field theory and you
can calculate how big you expect this
vacuum energy to be and you can compare
it to what we observe and the answer is
off by a hundred and twenty orders of
magnitude so that's a ten with a hundred
and twenty zeroes after it so that's
that's quite a big difference so that is
the mystery of dark energy so what what
dark energy is is sort of an umbrella
term for whatever this thing is that's
causing the universe to expand at an
accelerating rate it could be this
vacuum energy it could be a new force it
could be a new type of matter in the
universe we don't know what it is but we
call it dark energy and it makes up 70%
roughly of the of the energy budget of
the known universe can I give a slightly
different slant on so when Stein
formulated a principle of symmetry all
observers are equivalent
including accelerator observers that's
the basis of the general theory of
relativity and if you read his paper he
goes through not the wondering about
1915 or 1916 he goes through with that
symmetry argument and says these are the
only equations I can write down now I
have no doubt he knew that he was lying
because there is a so the equation you
know a lot of the principles of physics
are you take some some quantity and you
the solute the equations arise from
demanding to this quantity B extrema be
minimal or maximum be extremal in other
words small variations don't change it
so just about all the laws of physics
can be formulated that way as he did and
the term he extremize was the curvature
of space-time but there's another term
which he definitely knew about called
the volume
it's based you know every as a curvature
a mean curvature average curvature and a
total volume and I have no doubt that he
knew he could add such a term
why didn't he include that that's called
the cosmological constant term why
didn't include that in his equations
well Einstein wanted to calculate
everything in writing down that equation
he had to introduce one parameter that's
Newton's constant the strength of
gravity but that in a census defines the
scale of masses if he was going to
introduce this other term the
cosmological term the volume term it
would involve another parameter and he
didn't like to have anything he couldn't
calculate he really believed it
ultimately the final theory everything
would be calculable then he started
doing cosmology and he wanted a static
universe and he tried to solve the
equations and he couldn't get a static
universe so he said ah well there's this
other term which I didn't put in I can
use that now because I it's more
important for me to show my equations
work for the universe as well as for a
planet so he puts it back in he knows
he's gonna have to pay a price of having
an uncalculated he by the way never did
dimensional analysis and said I have to
introduce an uncountable constant it's
120 orders of magnitude smaller than
what I definitely know it must be the
case but anyway and then when he when he
learned that about the Hubble expansion
and other theorists who constructed
models of expansion he said well at
least I can get rid of this arbitrary
constant but you know so there's another
constant what I I think needs to be
emphasized is however that the discovery
of cosmic acceleration and the
measurement of that acceleration and
within the cosmological standard model
is in my opinion one of the greatest
triumphs of general relativity ever
because the
volume term from a geometrical point of
view or the vacuum energy if you move
that to the other side of the equation
as the source of gravity that is
observed fits Einstein's theory to ten
percent accuracy W equals minus one
that's a fundamental prediction of
general relativity the biggest sex in my
opinion lesson we learned from those
supernova measurements of the expansion
of the universe is that once again gen
relativity works and if you interpret
this term you can either interpret it as
the dynamics of the volume of the
universe or a source that produces that
dynamics the dark energy vacuum energy
any source consistent with general
relativity will give this particular
form of stuff that sources are at this
part of gravity but the stuff is weird
the stuff has energy and positive energy
that's always important of positive
energy you get into trouble if you have
negative energy but it has negative
pressure so you know an ordinary gas
pushes out although you try to put it in
a gas in a balloon it pushes out this
stuff pulls in it's like it had negative
energy but it doesn't as positive energy
but negative pressure and set negative
pressures it causes the expansion the
antigravity aspect but it has exactly
within 10 percent the same negative
pressure as positive energy and that
means that it looks the same to all
observers there's only one form of stuff
with energy and pressure that looks the
same to all observers and that's this
kind of stuff so the fact that that
expansion is of the
particular form that's allowed by
general relativity that Einstein
introduced for the wrong reasons and
then was glad to get rid of is I think a
fantastic success of general relativity
it's not the value that we have an issue
value you know theorist we've got a lot
of numbers we can't calculate yet we
have a lot of numbers very small numbers
that we have calculated already but it's
not an observation
you know experimenters right okay they
measure it but we need to explain it and
it's a bit hard to explain such a small
number but we've done so before in other
cases by similar orders of magnitude
right so ten to the hundred and twenty
yeah I mean I are sorry the way I give
the story usually is QCD of theory I'm
very fond of theory of the nuclear force
explains qualitatively you know an
Astrophysical terms within a factor of
two to ten the ratio of the mass of the
proton to the Planck mass the basic the
scalar gravity you know mass big enough
so gravity becomes strong that's 10 to
the 19 a ratio of two scales of mass if
you convert cosmological constant into a
scale of masses and furthermore invoke
broken supersymmetry
yes helps a lot you receive the orders
of magnitude you get you get but you
have to take the square root because
you're now you're comparing mass squared
you know cosmology constant doesn't have
dimension amassed so if I you know I
could say the QCD explains the mass
square to the proton over the Planck
mass squared which is 40 orders of
magnitude so we've done it before we
have tricks to do it yeah the best trick
is you take a large number you just
going to take its logarithms and that
logarithm is a reasonable number you can
imagine calculating but whether you
measure things with you whether you
measure per ass ratios demand
this numbers or their logarithm depends
on the physics it's a question of how
does physics vary we've learnt from the
standard model that physics varies
logarithmically that's our problem
because very so small T in other words
it's a big problem but we will solve it
it's it's an enormous theoretical
problem but it's not a mystery at the
qualitative first level
it's exactly what general relativity
would predict if you had a predict
another term not like the kind your
plane would that's consistent with the
principles of generality in addition to
the curvature obviously one's allowed in
fact a quarter standard falsity in
physics nowadays and even Einstein knew
that is that if something is allowed by
your general principles it's there you
can't anything that's allowed is
mandatory and it has some value and now
the question is why is it so small in
some units you could turn around say why
is Newton's constant so small well but
but the issue is how it receives quantum
Corrections no that's an issue of
gravity generally that's right but
that's why this is such a mystery
whereas say the electron mass is not
it's good it's the cosmological constant
in terms of the Planck mass which is
Newton's constant that's it so the
number you're constructing is G n lambda
right that is a small number whether I
attribute it to G or lambda or whatever
that's the dimensionless constant and as
I said it clearly is a challenge for
theorists but unless it is not just the
cosmological constant which is predicted
by the general principle of relativity
and normal physics and worked off the
bat to ten percent maybe better now
three persons
I regards as a challenge for theorists
but not a mystery before the mystery the
vowel is the fine-structure constant
well but that is sensitive to UV
Corrections in the same way that the
cause multiple consonant is I mean I
know that if I introduce high-energy
physics that have a huge change on what
the CC is going to be it's sensitive so
all everything in physics is sensitive
to what happens with the planks but
alpha is logarithmically sensitive well
good this is what's happening when
you've got theories arguable in my
opinion as an experimentalist they're
both correct but I want to say that the
challenge here is actually going back to
gravity is actually to your initial
question what is gravity we said what is
dark matter what is dark energy what is
black holes and to all these questions
we pause we and that's a big conundrum
where we probably are on the right track
we're not like completely lost in in the
sky but but it's going to take a lot of
work and thinking before we actually say
and now we've got it and by the way it's
not so big yes it is very big and we're
going to have to figure that out yeah I
think when from a layman's pointed point
of view I think that one of the exciting
things about science you know there's a
common perception that it's about coming
up with answers and it is but it's also
about coming up with great questions and
that's what's happened here with dark
matter and dark energy job' I was
wondering if you could take us through
some of the experimental side of gravity
coming up now you you you've worked on
LIGO and still are working on LIGO and
what that was initially the detection of
the gravitational waves from colliding
black holes but there are other
phenomena that could produce
gravitational waves that we at such a
scale that we can measure yes so it is
very important to approach I think
gravity from the expand to viewpoint
because whenever Theory have questions
maybe experiments can even post more
questions or answer some of them or
uncover information but we were not
aware so
in LIGO we had to put on a plethora of
sources you know anything anything which
does boom or toss this will generate
gravitational waves I just generated
some gravitational wave for you yeah
very small I can't see it but it
deformed you is a and the shape of the
room yes yes everything so so we need
very large masses yeah and it was kind
of a kind of a surprised at first we had
seen fairly big black holes merging but
that was very interesting because it was
not just the discovery of a black hole
binary but it was also a chance to test
Einstein's gravity in a in a really
strong field regime yeah and around
these black holes
you know gravity's is fairly violent
yeah so so when they merged there are
kind of three phases yeah one is they go
around each other yeah they get closer
and closer to each other and then they
kind of merge and then the the final
individual black hole which was just
born acquires the own rings down and
then there will be one black hole and
this means there are three signals you
know three signals carrying information
about the same same phenomenon and
comparing those three signals you can
actually deliver derive a lot of
information about Einstein's gravity we
were hoping to find something we always
want to find Einstein wrong and you know
the result is we always fight him right
yeah what a tragedy yeah so so we did
this study and actually it was
consistent with Einstein's theory but
but looking at more black holes maybe we
will find the deviation maybe we will
find the effects we didn't count on yeah
and there are other sources like like
you know a black hole which was born is
roughly as big as Long Island yeah it's
a fairly big one yeah so a smaller black
hole which is as big as Manhattan or a
neutron star which is very heavy star
1.5 times heavier than our Sun roughly
also the size of Manhattan
can be eaten by a black hole or two
neutron stars can actually kind of merge
and and rip each other apart and form a
black hole can happen and all of these
processes actually actually test gravity
on on very different scales and race
yeah so so in a sense the the beauty in
gravitational acceleration is that that
we just converted black holes from some
mysterious beautiful object on the sky
or our pacified laboratory yeah from now
on black holes and neutron stars can be
considered as our backyard laboratories
that we can study the properties of
gravity in a way we can never studied
before yeah so so the discovery was he
has a discovery we were so happy to have
it yeah I built like more than 16 years
on this I really wanted to discover
something why did I leave if I don't
discover something but but but but we
really kind of opened up new ways for
everybody dearest other experimentalist
you know there are people who are
actually considering what happens when
black holes eat dark matter
you know kind of kind of putting black
horse and dark matter together maybe
yeah so so there are there are actually
new ways to have experimental evidence
on on on on regimes of gravity which was
not observed before and and hopefully
they will give us a clue on on on on gr
or or the flaws of gr of course you know
quantum gravity experts will tell us
yeah gravitational waves need big masses
and will be very hard to observe not
always and we can say one thing about
this experiment which I I think
astonished me over the course of the
years that I was following LIGO that in
order to get the massive the effects of
the collision of these massive massive
objects a billion and a half years ago
to the lab the
love invoked quantum engineering type of
instrumentation so gravity and quantum
came together in the actual
instrumentation of how you detect these
collisions of this hugely massive object
objects that produce quantum effects on
the mirrors of the of the LIGO I think
this is spectacular in terms of the in
terms of technology and as you said
earlier this we didn't have twenty years
ago when when like or was conceived
there was you know they were talking
about interferometry but they were
asking quantum optics people in order to
go ahead and develop this this
engineering so I think this is a fit and
they deserve freely all the awards
they're getting all of them although I
think you got only two thousand dollars
compared to the other well III was born
too late so bad I will make up but there
is also one one more important aspect
you know whenever whenever you consider
the systems they are really alien you
know just imagine that to two objects
which are like 20 times 30 times heavier
than our Sun going around each other you
know your kitchen blender is a slow they
go around each other we like like like
60 percent of the speed of light yeah
it's like it's like it's like amazing
during the lifetime this object emitted
three times the mass of our Sun in
gravitational wave energy Wow
nature is having some program you know
my microphone okay so you you know it's
like we had a science run you know and
you do the mod we discovered at least
one gravitational wave because we
published it yeah and and if you if you
imagine that advanced LIGO will be three
times more sensitive that means the
volume three times three times three
like like number 27 30 yeah so that's
you know yeah why don't we you know one
today
they're going to be having discovery
papers one after the other
well we'll become well I want to there's
another aspect that black holes are
great things amazing and it's fantastic
to observe them directly there are also
very weird
they're called black holes because
classically there's so much mass in a
compact region that light can't escape
is pulled back into the black hole and
since light is travels faster than is
the limiting velocity means nothing can
escape from that region of space and
that raises the kind of conceptual
problem that general activity in the
hands of theorists is full of not
experimentalist unfortunately so you'll
you're gonna hopefully be able to see
within a few times the horizon of the
black hole that the region where light
can no longer escape from but according
to classical relativity there's no way
of seeing into a black hole so what what
what's in there and and this has been an
outstanding problem from the moment that
black people accepted that black holes
actually probably exists because it
raises very deep conceptual issues such
as the conservation of information so
one of the in quantum mechanics and all
of our successful theories in and in
traditional classical physics you don't
lose information if you know everything
about a system when you prepare a system
you follow its evolution you know you
can then do a measurement and you know
you know enough so that you can run the
experiment backwards in time you haven't
lost information in principle if you're
careful enough but in a black hole it
seemed that you did because stuff went
into the black hole and nothing came out
so you're either left with
black hole which according to the
equations becomes singular everything
becomes nonsensical curvatures become
infinite everything gets crossed nobody
knows what would happen and then Hawking
is famous because he discovered that in
a quantum treatment the black hole does
emit particles it actually emits thermal
radiation it looks like a hot object
thermal radiation tells you nothing
about what's going on inside an object
except its temperature otherwise it
looks the same so matter what you put
into a black hole what comes out will
look the same
eventually the black hole will evaporate
nothing will be left you've lost
information violates principles of
quantum mechanics and Hawking became
famous because he said general
relativity Einstein's theory and quantum
mechanics are mutually inconsistent and
it's interesting the history of that
which happened also not in the sixties
and the seventies eighties the
relativist were the general turdus said
okay we'll give up quantum mechanics
people like me the particle physicists
said now well changed in relativity and
that quarrel and study has been going on
for the last 40 years
by and large we won correct the sense
that even well because we now know
enough understand enough we think about
that even Hawking admitted that black
holes do not violate quantum mechanics
information is not lost in formation of
a black hole from which classically
nothing can escape thermal radiation
eventually I call disappears information
is preserved we have models of black
holes which we can
understand by ordinary quantum
mechanical means but how exactly this
happens and what happens at these
horizons if you could probe close enough
is still a subject of you know it's the
theoretical laboratory in which a lot of
the attempts to reconcile quantum
mechanics and general relativity occur
thor.fantastic laboratories we're going
to try to get to one or two questions
from the audience but we did promise
early on in the program that we would
talk about some of the the the wilder
prospects of how to resolve quantum
gravity does anybody want to go over
there well I just want to say so I think
it's a little bit of an overstatement to
say that quantum mechanics is
incompatible with general relativity so
I would say that in the so we talked
earlier about how we can describe
general relativity as curvature of
space-time and this was the original way
that Einstein conceived it but it turns
out there's an entirely equivalent way
of describing gravity and that's as a
force mediated by a certain kind of
particle and this is a particle known as
a spin to particle so we mentioned the
other forces earlier the electromagnetic
force the strong and weak force so these
are are perfectly consistent quantum
mechanical theories of forces that are
mediated by particles and you can
describe gravity in the exact same
language you can describe it as a force
mediated by this this spin-2 particle
and when you do this in fact you can ask
what is the the theory that I write down
if I only want a force that's mediated
by a spin-2 particle and what you find
is the unique answer to this question is
general relativity so you come back to
the exact same equations that Einstein
wrote down originally without ever
mentioning you know curvature of
space-time or equivalence principle or
all these other things that were used to
and so there there is a perfectly valid
theory at large distances or low
energies of gravity as a particle as a
as a force mediated by this particle
that's known as the graviton and I would
say that this is a perfectly healthy
quantum mechanical theory we just don't
know what it what it continues to look
like at the very very short scales
but I but I do think it's unfair to say
that that gravity is fundamentally
inconsistent with quantum mechanics I
think that Hawking's on it I never
believed no he said it for a different
reason
absolutely it is perfectly good we're
but we'd and you know from the point of
view of a low-energy Theory there's
never been a problem the problem is with
horizons with and edit but in fact I
don't think there are many people
nowadays who think there is any
incompatibility of general relativity
and quantum mechanics the final story
hasn't yet been given but I think we
have to keep saying this would yeah
because the usual thing is is that all
you know general dividend quantum
mechanics no no but it's not like that
that's right yeah so should we take some
questions waiting for the lights to go
up so we can see yes sir
well could you wait for the microphone
it's coming over Thanks do all quantum
mechanical processes take place in
space-time that's our model when you
walk you have a model that allows you to
walk which is space-time by the way that
model that infants construct of
space-time has been modified by special
relativity and general relativity
substantially so but it's still only a
model you don't directly perceive space
and time you perceive events which we
model is occurring in a in a four
dimensional dynamical manifold called
space-time some of us now believe
strongly and this is just in you know a
guide a clue that that it's probably at
in certain regimes when extrapolated at
very short distances or at a very strong
field from very high-energy collisions
where quantum gravity
in fact become important that that's a
poor model it it's it's only and a an
approximation to a better model of
physical reality it's in that sense that
between many people working in the spec
you doing these speculations trying to
understand properties of black holes or
other quantum gravity phenomena say that
perhaps we should regard space-time as
maz emergent phenomena as not being the
ultimate way we describe physical
reality but just a sort of
coarse-grained or a a model of reality
that's good for the kind of physics that
were the scales where it doesn't break
down there are strong indications of
that from many sources of our current
speculation and they're even more and
more precisely define toy examples of
how you can regard space-time space
especially as an emergent phenomena as
an emergent object gravity is an
emergent object from other ways of
looking at the same phenomena which
don't and don't don't have in their very
formulation either space or gravity so
not only the quantum mechanical
phenomena are happening in the ex-ante
space-time but when we draw diagrams and
we do calculations we have we have X for
X Y Z and we have T and we calculate but
this X and T now is emerging and
possibly from from the quantum so the
quantum winds not geometry anymore but
the quantum winds it's I think it's
spectacular thinking on how space-time
emerges and when we say space-time we
say gravity and so on so forth so it's a
revolution and thinking on how these
things will will evolve
I was just wondering what are your
thoughts on the idea of the Alcubierre
warp drive say what's that this is a
Star Trek thing this is the it's the
idea like that there's through the
Casimir effect people are able to
produce this um negative or exotic
matter which acts opposite of regular
matter which instead of pushing like
down in case space-time is pushing like
on two-dimensional view of space-time
and so pushing down it pushes up so like
you could use a spacecraft here and I
heard about this and somebody somebody
told me recently that NASA is pursuing
some some experiments on that I don't
know much about this I mean so I can't
speak to that my understanding of the
Casimir effect or the basic laws of
quantum field theory it's simply wrong
yeah
there is no anti-gravity period whether
you consider vacuum fluctuations or any
other one more question yes this one's
for Rachel you did such a fabulous job
of explaining dark energy it doesn't
relate in any way to dark matter or is
that is it just that you don't know what
either of them are yeah I think the
correct answer is we still don't know
what either of them are they so we gave
them both the name dark there are
theories that that try and relate the
two of them but I I think that the
current and most popular opinion is that
dark matter is probably some particle
and dark energy is probably just vacuum
energy and that the two things aren't
necessarily related to each other for
how beautiful it would befall the dark
and the black things that relate to
gravity can come off like sort of I be
explained in in the Cena's in a way that
is together okay well thank you very
much for your attention and let's thank
our panelists
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]